all right hello everybody welcome to the
knights class
so for the first lecture i covered
pretty common attacking motif or a good
one to know
the double bishop sacrifices this next
game i'm going to show
it's actually in the opposite direction
in this game between curious and smith's
love
from the famous zurich 1953 tournament
this game was actually
a must-win situation for carries who was
playing white
and he goes for what you might call a
kitchen sink attack right throw
everything in the kitchen sink at
smithslav
and as we're going to see smisov keeps a
cool head
doesn't ignore the attack doesn't treat
it carelessly
gives it all the respect it deserves but
nothing more
and smith's love after making sure that
white's threats are covered
breaks through in the center which has
been abandoned while white goes for the
kingside attack
and score is a crushing a key crushing
victory act right actually
to counter white's attack
so curry starts off with c4
typical english three c5
not going to talk too much about these
moves both sides are developing pretty
logically
white goes for another one of these
fiancatos these queen typhoon cuddles
with the bishop
this is still seen a decent amount today
nowadays it's more common to bring the
bishop out to g5 or f4 before you play
e3
which i do think is generally more
critical but of course this fianchetto
is completely viable
still seen some today and was extremely
popular for a long time
so the bishop comes to b2 black copies
white
and kind of their own bishop d4
takes takes and d5
again both sides are just developing
castles bishop b7
and if you were here for the previous
class the rookies class you can see a
lot of similarities right
if black's bishop is on e7 and these
pawns have already been traded
black already took on d4
but the structure is pretty similar
and if you go through older games
especially classic older games
you'll see it a lot
so there's nothing the knight is
crucially different and the last game we
looked at
this knight was on d2
which generally meant it wanted to head
for f3 and e5
here though the knight is more active on
c3 it puts pressure on d5
but there's less direct play around the
e5 square
right because this bishop is blocked
so at the moment there's nothing too
direct to do
white has a bit of extra space because
this pawn is a little farther back
and one thing this this bond structure
can lead to
it blocks this bishop out from this side
of the board
so this is a common theme especially in
a lot of d4 openings
where this pawn stays on e6
so you know also for example positions
where you end up with a structure
a structure like this for example
black's pieces are kind of cut off by
the kingside from the kingside by the
pawn structure
and this bishop has a nice diagonal
towards h7 so here attacks or ideas of
attacking are very common for white and
it's just because of how the pieces are
if we imagine that black could teleport
this bishop to g6
it would be far more difficult for white
to attack
or for example if this pawn were on d5
and black instead brought this bishop
out here
so this is a this is just an example of
how this pawn and piece structure
decides the plans so in the game after
rick c1
black leaves the pawn on d5 for the
moment plays rook c8
white plays rookie one and putting the
pieces on active square is nothing too
direct happening yet
and black goes for knight b4
so first of all does white one does
white want this trade
what do we think
yeah definitely not right this
especially in these positions where this
bishop's over here this is a key
attacking piece for white
so unlike the last game we looked at
bishop b1 is what white wants to play
white wants the bishop on this diagonal
what wants the bishop here what's the
problem with this
why can't white just keep the bishop
here and ask why are you playing knight
b4
so it's something direct the bishop on
d3 was actually doing something
important it isn't anymore
right s3 yeah so dc4 is hanging
right because actually ironically
because this knight's on c3
this pawn is actually undefended and the
bishop can't go to b1
because it was doing an important duty
guarding this pawn
this is why black played knight b4 and
this
this is good to realize because this is
the difference between a pointless
thread
and a useful one if white could just
play bishop b1
at some point white would play a3 black
has to go back
and white's happy enough to have this
bishop here white can go queen d3 next
after the knight comes back and create
many dangerous threats against the king
size
so the reason black goes knight before
isn't just to randomly attack the bishop
it's because thanks to this c4 pressure
right there's a reason black plays rook
c8
and only after that plays knight b4
because thanks to the pressure on this
c4 pawn white actually has to go bishop
f1
so white's forcing this bishop to a
square it doesn't really want to go
but it's doing an important job and it
needs to keep doing that job
right s3 and as you mentioned d-takes
also opens up this line for the bishop
again kind of like we saw in the last
game this game has a lot of similarities
but a very different outcome so bishop
f1
black immediately pounces on this week
in d4 square
and after a3 right white wants to kick
the knight out so the bishop can come
back
black uses opportunity to trade off a
pair of nuts
generally speaking
in these positions where
white has these king side attacking
prospects
and some not so much here but often
times white will have the worst bond
structure
you know something like an isolated pawn
very often black's happy with these
minor piece trades
right that's part of why black was
dreaming of trading off the slide square
bishop
because the fewer of those pieces are
left the less
the fewer prospects white has for
attacking on the king side
right the more likely you are to be
attacked
the happier you are trading off these
pieces
and you're right s3 so after bishop
takes c3
black would have knight a2
so this would attack the rook and you
can take the bishop and then take pawn
so this is no good for white and
actually because yes because of that
white is indeed forced to take the rook
instead
which normally this rook feels a little
awkward here
blocking the bishop but we're going to
see kiri's had
a distinct idea
so black goes back to c6
in this position
so i kind of touched on it this was a
very important game for the outcome of
the tournament
this is zurich 1953 tournament
it's a very famous one in history by the
way it has a lot of great games and
david bronstein wrote an excellent book
about it
but i highly recommend
curious went in with a basically
determined to win this game
and as we're going to see commits all
out to a king side attack
that doesn't prove justified
and generally speaking right this is not
the way you want to approach it
you want to say yeah right chess thinker
the
the name of the book is actually just
the tournament like i think it's
candidates 1953
is there a candidate's 1953
but 19 times out of 20 maybe more
you just want to play good chess and
find good plans and try to win from
there
if the position calls for an attack
great go for it
but when you're not well enough set up
for an attack
as is the case here i mean the king
side's kind of open but at the same time
white has very few pieces actually ready
to attack
so in this position i think a good
possible plan for white
and what i would like here is actually
just c5
and the idea is you can establish a c5
pawn
black does get a strong center but if
you play b4 b5 and c6
and this is not so simple to stop
you can create some crushing threats
with these queen side bones
so this i think would be a pretty
logical way for white to improve their
position
just to press forward on the queen side
and use what once you play c5 it's
basically upon majority
it's almost a four on two because it's
these six pawns that are interacting
instead of that though again white
decides to commit to an attack
so white goes knight e5
so black takes
if white takes here right black can take
here
perhaps trade queens and black's a
little better because this pawn wants
the bishop it's a little weak
small advantage but black is definitely
for choice here and of course there's no
attack right this is no way for white to
try
so white's idea was instead to take with
the rook
and after bishop f6 to go rook h5
right the upside here is that white can
quickly generate threats on the h-file
the downside is if white doesn't make
something big happen with these threats
the center is going to be painfully
underdefended because
white's committing all their pieces over
here
right if white doesn't make threats this
rook just looks silly
first of all just to establish white hat
that white has serious threats
let's say black plays a random kind of
useful developing move let's say queen
d6
can anyone find what's the quickest way
for actually white to create a very
strong attack here
and this this is very direct
now rook h3 would be the right idea
but it's more forcing
right more direct just take on h7
king has to take just go queen h5 check
and rook h3
i mean black's close to being mated on
the spot
anyone actually see what is the only way
for black to avoid a media mate here
we've got two checkmate threats
yeah g6 is the classic way to cover a
queen h8 mate threat but you also have
to cover queen h7
yeah this kind of thing is dangerous and
you do have to know how to respond to it
right you don't you definitely don't
want to ignore something a threat like
this or an attack like this
yeah so bishop h4 white takes with the
rook
and right trevejo f6
the king can escape here
but in exchange for what is now a small
material investment right
white has a bishop in a pond for a rook
exchange for a small material investment
or it's generating some huge threats
i'm not going to go too much into the
specifics you know i can try to bring
the other bishop in etc
but suffice to say this would be very
very dangerous for black
this is a defensive idea to be aware of
though just generally speaking again i
thought
i talked about it a bit in the last
lecture this f6
is basically the one way to avoid an h
file mate like this
it's a good defensive idea to know
okay so smith's love sees this coming
and plays g6 first
all right so now rook h7 just doesn't
work because there's no queen h5
and the bishop is ready to help on the
defense
so you can see we're not just ignoring
we're not ignoring the attack or
anything but we're also going to see
that
black also carries out his own ideas
and this is really the way to respond to
an attack like this
i mean step one really is to stay calm
right it's obviously dangerous
you obviously notice if an attack like
this works you're in big trouble
but all the same there's you just have
to work out as best you can how to
respond to it and how much you need to
respond to it
and again again i know this is easier
said than done
but you don't want to re you want to
respond only as much as is necessary
so white goes rook h3
now the first question to ask this is
this can be a very difficult question is
can we be greedy and take this rook
and this this again this is something
you should ask right if your opponent is
sacrificing a rook
you should at least consider taking it
and black does have a tempting
continuation here to take
queen takes but how about we try and
escape here for black
you could do bishop h4 in queen h4 that
would escape the m8
but we're down a lot of material now so
if we're going to do this we definitely
should not take the rook in the first
place
is this tempting idea rookie eight
and so no doubts missile have considered
this
but here white actually has a very
clever move
so first of all at first it even looks
promising if white goes queen h7
black's just running to e7 it's not a
dream square for a king but when you're
up a rook
you're prepared to make certain
concessions
but white but curious had a very clever
idea in my dear
and his move was actually just to play
a4
this move looks absolutely crazy right
you're attacking on the king side and
you play a4 on the queen side
queen h6 so queen h6 comes into play
right
bishop eighth the whole point is white
wants to play bishop a3
and just cut off the king's escape
now these lines are very tricky i'm not
going to go into them in depth because
it's a lot it's just a lot of analysis
but suffice to say that smith correctly
judged that if he accepted this rook
sacrifice
white's attack is very very dangerous
queen h6 is also in the air
in those lines as well
so actually in this position smith kind
of realized something
that to checkmate white actually needs
the queen
right if if white plays rook takes h7
the rook's not going to checkmate the
king
um how do you build this large
boardvision
so i would say the way to learn about
things like this
is honestly to look at games like this
and to play a lot of games
because right queen h6 is also a move i
would consider
generally speaking in this specific case
it's pretty clear that
there's no way for black to cover the h7
right black's not going to
salvage this h file black's one plan is
to bring the king out this way
so then the question is okay what can we
do about that
and you know if white had a knight if
white could get a knight to f5 or in
some other way cover e7 really the
question is
as white what can we do to stop the king
from running this way
and a4 is something that's easy to miss
things like this get missed all the time
even by strong players by grand masters
but that's sort of where it comes in
right this bishop can cover this and
it's actually
the ideal piece because it can cover all
of these
but generally speaking i would say
this is the kind of thing right you
learn about something like this from
seeing a game like this
and from looking at the variations
in this case i'm also i'm talking less
about the specifics and more about
the general correct conclusion that's
mislab reached that allowing this queen
to h5
was not worth it right accepting this
sacrifice is not worthwhile
so instead as is often correct smithslav
responds to a kingside attack by going
for his own play in the center
and he plays a very nice high-level move
he takes on c4
in this move right this move might seem
irrelevant at first
but it does a couple things
first of all let's say white just takes
the pawn back
right let's say first white just covers
the center
so we've opened up this bishop
can anyone see what can we do now
because this bishop now has freedom to
move
specifically because this bishop can
come to e4 now
black has something very specific in
mind
right yeah this bishop can cover each
other yep
a couple of you got it very nice
we can take the rook because now after
queen takes now we don't have to run
with our king anymore
we can just cover h7 with the bishop
and this is a case where you absolutely
should jump on this sacrifice
because now you can cover the one mating
threat white has
and actually here now that there's no
queen h7 mate white has no way to break
through
and you do have to check right you don't
just want to assume this but white has
no way to add pieces to the attack
and sure enough actually here white
sacrifice this attack just does not work
so this is what i mean when i say right
you want this idea of
you give the attack respect when it
deserves it
but if something like this doesn't work
it's very very important to take
advantage of that fact
and to see ideas like this bishop before
because if you don't take on h5 right
that's a whole potential rook you're
giving up
but okay when this muscle up takes on c4
right curious sees this idea that the
bishop will cover the main threats
and he rescues his rook he takes on h7
at the same time though is white making
a big threat on the kingside
is white about to checkmate us
so maybe right yeah the rooks
white doesn't have enough support
so let's ask this how can we improve our
position yeah this bishop is doing
excellent defensive work
only if white removes the bishop from f6
we do need to keep an eye on this piece
but okay so that being said as black
we've realized
at least for the moment
white's not threatening anything
crushing
how can we get some play of our own how
can we create some of our own threats
so there's a nice move here where black
starts creating some problems for white
right yep got it c3
so this rook's trying to attack but that
also means it's overloaded
right white can't take this pawn
if white takes
black takes and again overloaded
and meanwhile if white doesn't take we
now have a past pawn on the sixth rank
without a whole lot of defenders in
front of it
and so now curious goes queen c1
okay so first of all the mere fact that
white goes here
offering to allow you to take this
bishop that should at least set off a
warning in your head
the white's got something in mind
whether or not it works we should check
for ourselves
but what does white want to do here
white school what's he thinking
right yeah queen h6
so white wants to play queen h6 bring
the queen in the attack and check made
us from there
so now let's say all right let's try the
greedy round let's say we try and take
this bishop
white goes queen h6
well it's threatening rook hay with mate
so the second queen won't do us a lot of
good
all right material advantage doesn't
matter if you're getting mated
so can we though can we take the bishop
and after queen h6
can we try and defend h8 what if we go
who takes d4
so are we covering the mate threat can
white resign
i'm loading these questions a bit but
all right these are the things that's
important to consider
right very good yeah this is a key
attacking idea
and this is just something you should be
aware of you want to consider
you know you both want you want to get
by studying games some
some experience with these patterns and
you also want to think
you want to especially when there's a
lineup like this you want to think very
carefully
and sure enough rook g7 rokh8 also works
black tanks there's no made on h8 but
queen h7
and once again we're up mountains of
material but we're getting mated so it
doesn't matter
okay so white's threats are serious now
queen h6
followed by made on h8 or sacrificed and
are made on h7
and so this is what mieslav had to see
how to handle this
so let's ask this the queen can cover
the mate on h8
the queen can cover the mate on h8 how
can we escape the mate on h7
g5 would prevent queen h6 generally
speaking
i'm not a huge fan of moving pawns in
front of the king like this
let's see what happened here
i don't see an immediate refutation for
white
but there is actually a move that
there is a move that covers threats more
directly
let's see yeah i'm seeing some
interesting suggestions actually
now bishop g5 is
i mean at a minimum it leaves these
uncovered
yeah these are all moves you should
consider g5 like i said is a bit riskier
because it leaves h7 open
these moves my bishop g5 might work as
well preventing queen h6 is very
valuable
so the only reason the only thing i'm
going to say it's like these are good
these are good moves to consider
but smithslav actually found a defensive
setup that's even better
it's mislove
smithslav found a way to cover all these
mate threats
while at the same time generating some
threats of his own
so we actually took on d4 first
and the idea is white goes queen h6
so the h8 mate is covered
and a couple of you touched on this
already actually how do you cover this
rook sack and queen h7 mate idea
right the h8 mate has been defended how
do we defend against the h7 mate
right h7 is not mate if f8 is open
so you play queen d4 and then you play
rook fd8
so h8 has been covered adequately by the
bishop and queen
now this check and queen h7 is no longer
made because the king runs
and again this is what i mean by giving
the attack
just as much attention as it deserves no
more no less
all right this rook h8 queen h7 idea
when white plays queen c1
is aiming for a mate on h7 is very very
dangerous we certainly don't want to
ignore it
all right if we take on b2 and white
promotes or sorry wyco's queen h6
and we take or whatever we do if we try
to promote this is a very tragic end
so we don't just want to ignore things
altogether
at the same time if we if you see a
defense like this that looks strong to
you that looks like it holds everything
and at the same time right we've won
this nice d4 pawn this c3 pawn is an
absolute monster right
i've mostly been talking about this
kingside attack
but look at the center right if white if
white does not checkmate here
white's getting absolutely demolished on
the rest of the board
black's made some very useful progress
here so that's what i mean by striking
the right balance right
if black hadn't bothered to make
progress here and had been purely
defensive
their position wouldn't be nearly as
good
and this is true in chess in general
it's not just about and it's not just
when you're being attacked
right you want to give your opponents
plans as much respect as they deserve
no more no less and of course easier
said than done
but you should aim to do it and right
learn from
everyone makes errors in judgment
sometimes you know so you might miss
this rookie chain queen h7
but okay then you learn from that and
you address it next time
but here though as we'll see white
doesn't really have a follow-up
right there's no made on the h file so
these pieces are all just kind of stuck
in the middle of nowhere
right knowing what deserves respect is
the hard part
yeah i mean it takes a lot of experience
and like i said no one does it perfectly
but if you oh i would say more if
if you look carefully if right if you're
thinking if you're playing a game and
you look at a position like this
and you don't see a way white can
checkmate right if to buy your best
judgment
white has no way of breaking through and
punishing this then i would say you
should play it
right you should play what looks
strongest to you if you make an
error in judgment and you will sometimes
then you learn from that
and you adjust but if you avoid
something like this
even though even though you don't
see anything you're going to get in the
habit of playing scared chess
and not making the most of your position
and you can find plenty of players on
both extremes right the ones that attack
non-stop even when it's not justified
and the ones that defend against far too
many threats especially when they're
playing up
so our rook g3 and sacrifice on g6 for
white let's see so rook g3
i mean this is a move worth considering
so let's apply this principle here
right white has this idea of root g6 but
okay let's ask ourselves first what
happens after
chase g6 black takes white takes
white has ideas of checkmate
but then what if we go bishop g7
does white have a mate there
and if white does i don't see it so this
is an example of what i'm talking about
if you really wanted to defend if you
decided you needed to defend
bishop e4 for instance would be a move
i'd consider to defend here
right to cover g6 but given that i don't
see a win for white after rook g3
so actually i don't see any reason we
can't just take this bishop
and get our queen because i think we've
staved off white's attack
and you do have to be careful right you
have to consider rook g6 and rook f7
carefully
but after rook g6 fg6 queen g6 bishop g7
i mean black's king is open but white
simply doesn't have enough pieces
and that as far as i see this attack is
completely stopped
another thing white can try is rook f7
again trying to break open the king but
after takes check
king here queen h7 so i can try this
you definitely don't want to go back
here because that's mate
but after king d6 we're up an enormous
amount of material
and white just again white lacks the
fire power
so this is what i'm talking about in
action rook g3 is worth considering
now you're right so in this position
yeah what
why it does have rook d3
that's a good pin to notice but we're up
so much material it doesn't matter
we're already up a rook in bishop so
it wins the queen but
i mean the simplest way would actually
just be to take
and this b2 pawn right we have two rooks
and a bishop for a queen
this is go this pawn is going to win us
the game
a more aggressive way and what looks
strongest i mean so this is a good move
to see right it wins the queen
but that's just not enough white's
invested so much into this that you can
do rook c1
and if white wants the queen i can have
it we're going to get a new one
and again this all this all merits
thinking about
all right resignable at that point i
would say especially once black gets the
new queen
this all merits thinking about but it's
very important not to get in the habit
of avoiding positions like this
as black just because it looks dangerous
it is dangerous
but if there's nothing there then
there's nothing there
and after rook t3 we can safely take the
bishop
so root d8 and white kind of realized
this
white realized the attack was losing
steam and just saved the bishop
of course playing a move like this when
you're attacking is never a great sign
black goes bishop g7 to kick the queen
out
queen g5 and queen f6
and again if you're playing queen g5
queen g4 in bishop c1 when you're trying
to attack
it's usually a sign that things went
wrong somewhere
okay now what should we do as black now
we've kind of staved off this attack
what's the next step
yeah bishop g5 is an idea we should keep
that in mind
right just c2
yeah c2 is the simplest
yeah we just want to play rook d1 and
we're just promoting our pawn right we
we have a past pawn on the seventh rank
you don't usually see
this kind of past pawn at this stage of
the game
but so much the better
rook so rook d1 is a huge threat
if white plays bishop g5 white can try
this to go for an attack but
my first inclination here is just to
actually give up one of the queens
maybe just promote
now you always want to check on rook h8
and such
but white's only getting one of the
queens back
and blacks up a piece
not only that but this is coming
so instead of that white goes bishop e2
to cover the threat to d1
black goes rook d4 and this is an
elegant finish
right if the queen moves if the queen
moves away from d1 like this
this ends the game check me
so instead white goes f4 to keep the
queen on g4
now one last combination to end the game
oh good call s3 yeah you're right that
is actually just a direct checkmate with
a queen sack that is even stronger
nice catch
right so now white's still covering d1
but he's also opened this diagonal
so rook do you want check bishop takes
and queen d4 very nice
yep checking the king and whatever
white's next move is
we're gonna get ourselves a second queen
and here white resigned
let's see rook takes up four well so
rook d one just wins
right rook d one queen d4 is going to
get us a new queen
but after rook four the problem is the
bishop covers it so i think after queen
f4 it's not so clear
even this should be good for black
because you're winning the bishop
but it's not nearly as good as rook d1
because this just lets us promote all
right we're not even winning a piece for
our new queen we're just getting a new
queen
and winning a bishop at the same time
and here white resigned yeah i think a
very instructive game right we saw
white had some genuine threats and black
gave those their due
black covered the h8 mates and the h7
mates
but but when black had their chance
right smith pushed his pawn to c2 and
created monstrous threats in the center
that white was unable to answer right a
big part of why this pawn was so strong
is all these white pieces are over here
thanks alberto good to see you
yeah so i think an excellent defensive
game from smuslov
and a great example too of how defense
does not mean only defending
now you cover the mate threats you cover
the serious threats but when the threats
stop
you also go for your own play
and white play e3 i mean yeah i can move
a piece to e3 but
this is with check black's going to be
up a queen in a moment
and actually white's also just getting
mated in a couple moves
so there's just no move that defends
against the second queen
alright so we don't have enough time to
cover this second game
the second game i was interested in but
actually this being the knights class
let me do honor to the name and show a
couple night puzzles
this one's a bit of a favorite of mine
all right so here's this study is this
position is white to play and maintain
two
like i said so we don't have too much
time so
let me show off some some nights for the
night's class
nice
i see we have some experienced puzzle
solvers here
you know to look at the queen sack first
all right queen takes f8 is tempting and
of course in the game queen takes f8
would be a completely reasonable way to
win quickly
but the way to maintain two is actually
queen d7
knight takes and knight e6 checkmates
very nice yeah and if you do a lot of
puzzles you'll see this pattern again
this kind of checkmate
yeah it's a very nice final position
right in a game right there's nothing
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
playing queen takes f8 in the game
it is fun to try and see where the meat
is
all right this next position this is
actually the end position this is right
near the end
of a much longer study that is a very
nice puzzle
but just to finish it up here this is
white to play and win
right normally this is a winning
material advantage normally bishop and
two knights against bishop is a win
the problem here is black is threatening
to just win one of our knights
and if black can do that or trade off
the bishops then it's a draw
so what can we do as white here
so knight g8 is an idea if king g6 or
king g7
right knight takes king takes and we
have the bishop and knight win
so check if we can just take trade the
knight for the bishop that we have our
win
but hang on what if king h5 the problem
with knight g8 is king h5 and black
still wants to trade off the bishops
very nice chest thinker so knight g8
king h5 and they say two knights against
the king is a draw but
here's one of a very few exceptions
knight f3 checkmate
and we have another two nights mate
all right so what about king g6
so that's of course that's a move the
key here is after king g6
we take the bishop and of course this is
not a simple checkmate
but it is a winning position for white
it's a good one it's worth knowing too i
would say
oh so after taking well king here takes
well king g6 now right we have ourselves
a winning end game again
something like this
but the key here is that
yeah i know the bishop at night made is
not easy it's been messed up at high
level more than once
but it's doable i've had to do it myself
a few times actually
yeah again black can't take the bishop
and if black goes back
we keep a winning amount of material
all right yeah nice solving guys
actually both
i thought especially this second one
especially is a little sneaky so that
was a quick solve
yeah i mean if you're playing black if
you're playing black and you see this
checkmate and you trust your opponent
i'd say it's absolutely worth it right
test them make them actually win this
end game
so as i said it is not simple
but as far as the studies concerned we
can certainly say this is a one position
for whites with absolute confidence
and as i said well it's tricky once you
know the technique
it's definitely doable
yeah i might perhaps i'll actually talk
about that in a future lecture because
like i said i've actually i've had to do
it a few times
all right guys so i'm going to wrap up
with that
the other game i mentioned i can cover
next week
yeah thank you all for watching yes if
you have any questions or comments
as i wrap up feel free to leave them in
the chat
i hope you enjoyed it will see you at
five chess thinker so yeah i'll be on
puzzlers paradise
on youtube at 5 pm central so feel free
to give that a look
and i hope to see you then
yep five so 5 central on youtube
or for me 3 p.m pacific
thanks again bye